hello and welcome to this video wine off
as my opponent and he plays on oh it's a
game but I'm worse off gambit yeah what
do you do against that my normal choices
knight c6 but I wanted to look at
something else no not the king let's do
this and that let's just test if White
has enough compensation yet d5 here is
to move you want to plain looks very odd
though it looks a bit odd
yeah I'm experimenting here as I
mentioned my normal move is some 496
down but let's see what happens
okay c6 it's a really odd pawn structure
there hmm
I don't like that if he gets to take on
f6 you're moving the night yes that a
move it could be possible I mean it
looks a bit weird but what exactly
happens here like 25 36 Bishop g5 who
should be 7 it's not a problem
[Music]
maybe it's as playable I was going to a
castle
look playable I don't like that my night
on earth at night that was on f6 that
now is on d7 exactly my king side is
definitely a little bit it's not very
well defended
I came let's try to get the bishop out
as quickly as possible
that's his six Bishop g4 and the next
moves on a very good day I can play f6
and get rid of that pawn but that's not
so easy to accomplish yeah he's taking a
bit long him really that was the most
pressing thing
it looks extremely slow
maybe unite now the night this is good
yeah why go backwards if you can go
forward 97 I was just thinking maybe him
but this is okay I'm attacking me five
and it's not a winner a pawn and there
are always tactics like 95 95 95 Bishop
h7 king and queen h5 takes that those
kind of tactics but it's it's an active
piece and he seems intense to lose on
time even though where were the
increment it's tough to lose on time
every day you have to be extremely slow
and never really had gained speed to
lose a game more time but what are you
doing here just develop pieces you're
playing a game a bit you know
okay it doesn't look scary giving me the
bishop a pair for nothing much okay so
he's attacking see for Bishop six most
normal well that's good okay
[Music]
hmm maybe I should have reconsidered
that and to not play but should be six
that's a little less annoying yeah it's
a bit of an annoying move
hmm okay
that's true I mean I don't trend to take
on a six but still okay I want to make
sure that it's not harassing my piece of
stem Jim that didn't go too well really
weird I mean my position was definitely
a lot better there and now it's not
I know it's nothing special I was
threatening the Becker image so couldn't
take that mm should d5 me beam oh he's
playing on the increment so if I tick
here and then shake I can also check
immediately but let's take this Bishop
takes this 95 and here I got some checks
coming check can check on g6
which is not actually that great I mean
it's an okay move but it doesn't really
help me all that much
hmm really unhappy about this and now we
lose on time but not game I mean it was
one of the best positions they have
ahead and then loses on time would it be
it game yeah I'm interested in how I
spot this because like here I should be
close to winning and it didn't
materialize okay yeah first of all let's
check them this is an interesting gambit
I know that this is a playable move but
it is in fact quite risky for blanket
it's something I have to check at one
point because it's very principled just
take everything and claim that you
cannot just sacrifice the whole center
but probably White has enough
compensation the move I usually place 96
which leads to a satisfactory position
edge just a fairly harmless version of
the two knights Italian and this is
another option so let's see
he went c3 takes takes and now e5 is
most principled he 5 d5 yeah and so the
engine at least and this not very
extensive depth confirms that I should
be okay here it's again it's not a deep
calculation but still maybe he really
has to take care and then this is this
position which is weird it's a weird
position you can probably take here or
yeah maybe checking a tick here it's
just extremely shocked I have no clue
here what's going on material I think is
equal huh yeah it's equal material this
is probably what you should do and I'm
not super happy with this position but
again business was more an experiment
than anything else
yeah here it seems to me that I'm okay
open the bishop and this is just wrong
yeah why would you play
a porn when you have all the
compensation I get towards the kingside
yeah like here here everything is
kingside based okay took and played the
special b6 yeah
with hindsight maybe a move like Bishop
g5 is interesting or Queen d5 simply
covering everything there Queen by 5
root g1q into 6 or 24 looks ok if he
goes a 6 now I think I'm just taking it
or take e5 Union okay this is hanging
yeah this wasn't so clear really and the
engine wants to play b5 I briefly
thought about it but I couldn't really
you know what I didn't really spot is
that now this is actually a move because
rook e1 is not possible anymore with the
Queen on b5 and then this is definitely
stronger than Quincy area and in the
game that that wasn't all that fantastic
yeah 97 was a move yeah that's and I
never looked at this I always thought
that I'm still a little bit better which
is true but it's not a anything decisive
okay now Queen B 1 Queenie for was good
yeah that's true
it looks strong double attack oops
it's a pure coincidence that he's not
using a piece immediately at IKEA this
got 92 and quintics got quincy sex now
do you you're just better you should be
5 or something I've played this and now
he ignored this idea to take on f3 which
isn't even the strongest which it should
lead you on a better position for black
okay that's the final position and I
wasn't wrong it is the best position
that he ever had in the whole game
problem yeah some Evo h4 you just
continue to play it's equal material I
have the a porn the night yeah has
potential to improve but this is not a
good piece but the night is also not
great at the moment made maybe I can't
improve it but it's not easy to do yeah
I shouldn't lose on time there you can
make basically any move them okay guys
thanks for watching